one of the great things that I love
about this subject is that when you're
trying to construct a proof an argument
it's clearly more than one way to argue
that something that is true and so it
takes some creativity to think about
what is the most elegant or what's the
most efficient way to do this so I've
come up with one
you always might be different I'll come
to those different ones in a minute okay
so I won't you have a look at this line
we established that lkm was 45 degrees
once I know what this angle is I want to
try and move forward from there each
line in the proof builds on the ones
before it okay so that's why you can see
lkm actually written it in backwards
order here lkm a P is in the next line
that is in my proof and this happens
quite often
okay now p MN where is that have a look
it's here now I want you to look there
is anyone else going straight to angle p
MN anyone else yeah okay great
um you can see if we go there it's I've
said it's equal to these two angles in
the other triangle CP MN is in this lo
triangle and these two let me mark them
in for you up here and over here right
what's the reason that p.m. n equals
these two over here what's the reason
say it again
Co interior so I've got two angles that
are both on the inside but those go into
your angles are usually between parallel
lines right and I don't really have any
parallel lines here so that's a good
idea but for a different question what's
going on here
I think it's that this is an exterior
angle isn't it to remember that when we
look at polygons the exterior angle of a
triangle equals the sum of the two
opposite interior angles that make sense
so that's my reason over here
and that's really important right now
you may not have gone down that line of
argument that's fine it's just different
we'll find out at the end if we have the
same thing so I've got my reason here
is that the exterior angle I can already
think by the way I've got at least two
other proofs in my mind for how we could
do this so if yours isn't this that's
okay I'll talk about the other ones in a
second the exterior angle our of what's
the triangle chord ml K equals the sum
of the what some of the what they are
opposite and they are interior so the
opposite interior angles now before I
move on any further through my proof I
just want to make a note the reason why
people including me when I was in you 10
dislike this topic is because you've got
to write so many words so many words
right and if they people are sticklers
for the amount of detail that's there
okay I would put to you the reason why
there are so many more words is because
we try to prove something we're trying
to make a statement about something
that's true forever always no matter
what kind of pair of triangles you draw
together okay so that's why we want our
argument to be convincing all right lkm
MLK that's 45 plus 90 that's hundred
thirty-five isn't it are you okay with
that 135 okay I've got these two angles
over here have a look at where I use
them this one I should put a stars on
them and this one why are they equal
it's a reason I've already used on the
board equal angles opposite equal sides
you can go ahead you can write that
right and then have a look at the
structure of this line I haven't said
anything about it and I bet you can
guess one two three angles a hundred
eighty Aries what's the reason it's the
angles of a triangle yeah but it's a
different triangle so you can write that
as well okay dot dot dot
okay I'm almost there now I'm almost
there can you help me finish this I've
substituted this for X and this for X
because I showed that they were both
equal see the Black Stars I'll
substitute that 135 how can I do that
I proved it from the 45 plus 90 earlier
on okay so now let's collect some like
turns over here what do I get on the
Left 2x I want the X by itself so I
might is what the same time to subtract
135 from both sides
maybe with 45 so what's X are you happy
now can someone tell me a different way
of doing this because there's more than
one Nathan what are you yep this angle
here
yep see this 195 we didn't have to do it
through this way I could have said right
well I'll find out I've got that this is
45 I can make that 45 as well and angles
on a straight line add up to 180 so
that's good I get to the same and go
there for Pearman and then from there I
everything else is identical okay
what's another way we could do this
someone give me a different way Nathan
use the straight line I use the opposite
interior the exterior angle has someone
got a different way you know where
Nathan found this guy here found is 45
see that one do you notice it's also an
exterior angle what's it the exterior
angle of have a look it's these guys
isn't it don't the two black stars add
up to 45 do you see that okay so same
deal we all arrive at the same Inn so
that's the beautiful thing about it even
though it's eight different parts